Grüß euch , ich bin der Wachtmeister Reinhard
Eibel vom Jägerbataillon 17 zu meiner linken steht
der Wachtmeister Max Penz und wir zwei stellen
euch heute das schwere Bergefahrzeug HX2 vor.
Wir haben ihn nun zwei Wochen bei uns. Wir
beide haben eine fünf wöchige Ausbildung in
Zwölfaxing absolviert und der Max wird euch jetzt
in das Fahrerhaus mitnehmen und es euch erklären.
So wir schauen uns das ganze jetzt von drinnen an.
Übrigens geschützt und gehärtete Kabine bis Kaliber 12,7 mm und Mienen sicher.
Wir sind jetzt in der Kabine angekommen. Zum Fahrzeug selbst: Es eine Produktion von
MAN und Rheinmetall. Ich kann mit dem Fahrzeug andere Fahrzeuge abschleppen und
bergen. Das fängt an mit dem Pinzgauer, L200 bis hin zum Husar, Pandur
oder das Sattelzugfahrzeug bis hin zu den größten LKW´s des Bundesheeres.
Wir haben eine Eigenmasse von 34 Tonnen , sind knapp 11 Meter lang, 2,60 Meter breit
und 3,80 Meter hoch. Nun kommen wir zur Kabine. Es gibt nicht viele Besonderheiten
oder unterschiede zu einem normalen LKW. Ich habe meinen Bildschirm.
Mit diesem habe ich die vier Fahrzeugkameras im blick. Jetzt nehmen wir euch noch mit
auf einen Rundgang um das Fahrzeug. Wir sind jetzt am
schweren Bergefahrzeug und ich zeige euch jetzt
die Komponenten  die sehenswert und interessant sind.
Gleich vor uns haben wir den Ladekran des Fahrzeuges. Dieser hat
eine maximale Ausladung von 7 Metern. Mit dieser Ausladung ist er in der Lage 2,8 Tonnen zu heben.
Ganz hinein gezogen ist er in der Lage bis zu 6,8 Tonnen zu heben.
Mit dem Ladekran habe ich die Möglichkeit
ein Powerbag, also den Motor von einem Mannschaftstransportpanzer Pandur
aus dem Fahrzeug heben beziehungsweiße eine
Anhängerkupplung am Fahrzeug montieren. Dahinter befindet sich der Lichtmasten. Das ist ein
pneumatischer Lichtmast. Dieser wird mithilfe von Luftdruck ausgefahren und ist komplett LED. Um
bei einer Bergesituation in der nacht die Bergestelle komplett
zu beleuchten. Für das Fahrzeug selbst, habe ich eine rundum Beleuchtung an den Staukästen.
Die wir im laufe des Rundgangs noch sehen werden. Hier geht es weiter mit
unserer Hauptseilwinde. Das ist eine Bergewinde. Diese hat eine Zugleistung bis zu 27 Tonnen. Ich
kann damit jeden Pandur  aus dem Schlamm heraus ziehen.
An dem Bergearm sind die Seilwinde und
die Anhängerkupplung. Diese hebe ich wie schon angesprochen mit dem Bergekran
hinten herunter.  Wir haben 3 Seilwinden auf dem Fahrzeug montiert. Die
Bergewinde mit 27 Tonnen Zugleistung. An dieser habe ich 80 Meter Seil zu verfügung. Dann hab ich eine Rahmenwinde
am Fahrzueg , diese zeigt euch dann der Reinhard. Die Rahmenwinde kann nach vorne und hinten
ausgeschert werden und ist auch eine Selbstbergewinde. Somit kann ich mein Fahrzeug selbst
aus einer Bergesituation sichern. Die dritte Winde, ist eine Hilfswinde. Diese befindet sich unter
mir. Die Winde hat eine Zugleistung von 1 Tonne und 250 Meter Seillänge und ist dazu gedacht
das schwerere Hauptwindenseil auszuziehen.
Passt, jetzt schauen wir uns das Ganze von unten an.
Jetzt machen wir den Rundgang unten um das Fahrzeug.
Hier sind wir bei dem Staukasten 1. In diesem Staukasten befinden sich die Adapater
die ich brauche wenn ich eine Fahrzeug aufnehmen will. Die Hubbrille und die verschiedenen Zurrgurte.
Im Staukasten 2. befindet sich die
persönliche Ausrüstung. Dazu zählen unser Rucksack und Verpflegung wenn wir länger unterwegs sind.
Im Staukasten 5. befinden sich die Versorgungsleitungen.
Die wir zweck Kamera, Luftleitungen und Elektronik anbringen müssen wenn wir ein Fahrzeug abschleppen. Dahinter befindet
unser Bergearm. Der Bergearm ist in der Lage 16 Tonnen zu heben. Zusätzlich haben wir auch noch die
Bergewinde die 27. Tonnen Zugleistung hat. Hier kommt noch die Hilfswinde heraus. Mit dieser wird
das Abschleppseil heraus gezogen.  Da dies mit den Händen zu schwer wäre.
Seitlich sehen wir noch die Rahmenwinde , mit einer Zugleistung von 12. Tonnen.
Gehen wir weiter zum Staukasten 6.
Im Staukasten 6. befindet sich das Bedienelement für den Bergearm, den Kran und die Notbedienung.
Also alles was mit Elektronik und dem Funk zu tun hat. Zusätzlich habe ich noch die Steuerung
für den Lichtmasten.  Im Staukasten 4. befindet sich die Bergeausrüstung. Diese ist für Verkehrsunfälle mit eingeklemmter Person.
Hier sehen wir den Hydraulischen-Spreizer, den Trennjäger und die persönliche
Schutzausrüstung. Im Staukasten 2. befinden sich die
Umlenkrollen und weiteres Equipment welches man bei einer Bergung benötigt.
Hier befindet sich noch unsere Rahmenwinde und jetzt zeigen wir euch was unser 545 PS starker HX2 kann .
Legen wir los!